well so many of us document our dogs
lives on social media both of us do
we're guilty
they're all cute and this afternoon we
have a story that may just inspire you
yeah that's right well in this specific
story it's about a trio of dogs and an
owner who believes that everyone
deserves a shot and the story of their
lives together here is mary jane bellius
every time we pass people they get big
smiles they want to take pictures tim
libsy owns the three australian cattle
dogs known as beauties and the bolt
outfitted with goggles to protect their
eyes livsey says it's quite a show
wherever they go it's a sight to see and
it's not just the dog's appearance
catching people's attention but they're
heartwarming story too lipsy adopted
each dog so bella is the oldest one i've
had her for the longest she's nine years
old i got her in north carolina
her litter was abandoned bolt i got next
he came he actually came from a breeder
he was born with a broken tail so he
couldn't be sold as a show dog and then
bonnie she's deaf got her last
she's five years old
she came from arkansas
the old owner didn't want her anymore
the furry friends share a load of hiking
and camping adventures proving there's
nothing a dog can't do even for bonnie a
lot of people think a deaf dog or a
blind dog can't
you know needs to stay at home i can't
really do much but
i've proven that wrong every day with
with taking bonnie out and i advocate
for people to
adopt deaf dogs because there's really
no difference lipsey says they are a
tight-knit crew bella and bolt do a
great job of guiding bonnie even saving
her from a coyote bolt turned around
first i heard his ferocious bark his
mean bark bella turned around and took
off running time i looked back the
coyote was already running in the other
direction the dogs also have quite a
following on social media and will even
be featured on the 2023 cover of
adventure dog's calendar mary jane
vallieza live local now